Film Courage: Chris I want to hear about you
taking this week long drive across country?
Chris von Hoffmann, writer/director: It was
like 4 or 5 days?
Film Courage: Okay.
You said you didn’t totally plan it out
to come to LA?
You had been thinking about it for a long
time or…?
Chris von Hoffmann: I had been thinking about
it since I was in high school.
I mean I had been wanting to move out here
for acting at the time.
But at a certain point I was like ‘I think
I’ve done all that I can do in New York.’
I mean I was hardcore wanting to pursue filmmaking
at the time and New York just was so theater
driven and I love theater, I love Broadway
and all of that.
I love that stuff and I wanted to be an actor
on stage for a long time.
As far as the film business, there is a lot
of film that shoots out there but LA is just
is the capital of movies.
And so I just thought I’ve just got
to do it.
I recommend it to a lot people.
I mean a lot people fly their cars out.
Film Courage: You drove?
Chris von Hoffmann: Yeah, through Oklahoma
and New Mexico and stayed at these cheap motels
and these weird places…like Scottsdale,
Arizona and I got to see all of these places.
Film Courage: Did you see real-life drifters?
[Chris is writer/director of the horror film
DRIFTER].
Chris von Hoffmann: Probably?
I mean it was like 2012.
I came across some weird people, yeah.
Just in different corners of the town.
But I definitely recommend it.
I loved the experience, I definitely recommend
it.
I hated pulling over for gas or pulling over
to use the restroom because I love to keep
moving, going.
It was a very transcending, very therapeutic
experience because you’re not thinking about
what’s ahead of you just yet.
You’re not thinking about the past at all.
And it’s such like an in-moment kind of
thing.
It was great and one of the best experiences
of my life driving out to LA.
You’re not thinking about anything, there’s
nothing really hardcore to think about yet
in that tiny amount of time and you’re sort
of just going moment-to-moment and then you
move to LA and you’re like oh ‘Now I’ve
got to get back to reality’ and then it
gets gruesome.
But that brief amount of time was great.
Film Courage: Were there things leading up
to that moment where you said “Okay, I think
now is the time,” you were 24 you say?
Chris von Hoffmann: I think making that short
probably and then I remember thinking ‘Should
I not make this short and move out to LA blindly?
Or should I wait a few months, make the short
and then move out to LA?’
That felt like the best bet to do something
like that because I didn’t want to go out
there with literally nothing.
And so I just made the short and then screened
it at this place called The Producer’s Club
in New York City (which is on 44th street).
It’s a little blackbox, they do a lot of
rehearsals and plays there, but they also
do screenings and they have a projector that
you can rent.
And 70 people came to it, so it was a nice
little turn out for that movie and they responded
to it very well and so that boosted up your
confidence and then you go to LA and all of
your confidence and ego is just shattered
within minutes so…
Film Courage: Every day of every year.
Chris von Hoffmann: Every day is just like
constantly cutthroat and brutal.
I think it was great to have that short film
in my back pocket because that helped me to
meet other people for later for other shorts
and they could take me somewhat seriously
that I’m not a total idiot, that I can make
movies.
And then I start to make more and more shorts
with more and more people I was meeting out
here and just honing the craft and learning
just about the nuts and bolts of movies.
Film Courage: Was there a moment that you
thought about turning the car around?
Chris von Hoffmann: No.
It was a pretty straight shoot just like there
is no turning back.
I was just at the point in my life where I
was like there was nothing more for me to
do out in New York.
I know what I want to do right now, I know
this path I want to take and New York is just
not going to do it for me.
And if I’m serious about this and serious
about pursuing directing and wanting to be
a writer/director then I have to move to Los
Angeles.
And I remember one of the first things is
when I moved out to LA I went to a screening
of SLITHER (James Gunn’s movie, one of his
early movies) and I went to The Aero Theatre
(it was the first time I went there) and James
Gunn was there for a Q&A and the first thing
that came out of his mouth was “You have
to move to Los Angeles.”
And I was like “Well, it’s been validated
(now I feel good about this).”
I know some people live in Toronto and try
to do film in New York and all of that and
I guess there is work all over the place.
But LA is the heart and soul of it and it’s
just so much more convenient for everybody
and all the deals are made out here and everyone
is in sync.
It is like a bubble and it’s good to be
part of that bubble I think.